[Music]
I would just say to every like everybody
going and like doubting themselves and
not being sure just like find like a
fundamental set of values that you would
apply and stick to them and and believe
in yourself because if it's possible
that means you have no excuses you need
to work towards it
gamita is a biotechnology company using
cell engineering to develop novel
Therapeutics for diseases of the female
reproductive system
one thing I've noticed is that ovaries
age up to five times faster than the
rest of the woman's body relative
decline in ovarian function results in
infertility which is why we have these
sentences that in ovaries geriatric when
a woman is in her like mid to late 30s
when the rest of her bodies are only not
and then later on menopause is like an
absolute decline of ovarian function and
menopause is also associated with
women's life expectancy so it's almost
like a mirror of the Aging that occurs
in her body so even though we end up
living longer after menopause we women
end up having more diseases than men and
a funny fact was that it's really only
humans and four types of whales that
experience menopause and ovarian aging
as we do so perhaps it's not even an
evolutionary imperative if we can now
expect to live even to a hundred the
fact that we spend two-thirds of our
life in fertile and half of our life in
this stage of poor health post menopause
is just no longer fit for purpose even
though if it wasn't correct did by
Evolution so I felt that there was a
huge amid need to provide Therapeutics
so medicines real medicine that will
allow us to gain the function we lose
throughout life we have one billion
women living with menopause right now
there were studies showing that up to a
third would take treatments for it if
they if they good treatments existed so
I finally felt that there is an unmet
clinical need where we believe that we
can add value right now
it's a great Market established
healthcare industry unlike aging which
is like a slow subtle sophisticated
process and something I was immensely
passionate about and I felt that is is
necessary and important for the society
I was born in South Serbia and I did my
education in the United Kingdom and I
was a medical student at UCL medical
school and after second year of medical
school after finishing my neuroanatomy
exams I actually got discovered through
this Talent competition which was called
the F actor it was the very first year
it was being organized and the idea was
it would be like X Factor but for stem
so through that I really learned what's
venture capital I was incredibly excited
by the ability like the lack of
hierarchy that people would think that
you're smart and write you a check and
I'm like oh because it's not so common
in in medicine there's entrepreneurial
Community showed to me a path how you
could form companies and solve the
problems you're passionate about so
since then I've been in the space trying
to really use technology and this
entrepreneurial Spirit and the support
of entrepreneurs to help me solve the
problems I feel I could contribute to
and are really important in healthcare
[Music]
we raised 40 million so far and we were
fortunate enough to be backed by some of
the leading investors like future
Ventures inside Partners bold Capital
salt Lux Capital so I think people have
really understood that this has been an
underfunded area and then both
infertility and just diseases of the
familiar productive system fundraising I
mean it's it's always a it's tough but
it's like a good challenge and usually
you'll learn a lot it helps you
delineate where you don't want your
company to go and where you want your
company to go when everything happened
around the Supreme Court decision I felt
personally very kind of okay what did we
do now there were some scares or would
it affect the SSA reproduction industry
I spent that weekend speaking with all
of our physicians and employees
understanding what will happen because
we obviously work with clinics in many
states
different politics and what happened was
that actually there have so far been no
consequences on assisted reproduction
and IVF I fundamentally believe that you
should not let any crisis go to waste
every tragedy should be turned into a
business opportunity and that's how I've
operated so what I've we've decided to
do after reflecting on it we should
really use this to shine light on on
many things that have been fragmented in
women's health
I'm extremely passionate about two
things in life because those are two
things that experience Healthcare and
education so I would really like to make
it because then I can go to any child
that is hiding in the basement from some
war and tell them look if if I've done
it then you can do it and it's
completely possible foreign